[Música]
le voy a hacer una pregunta cuando
ustedes trabajaron en una universidad o
en una fundación una organización de la
sociedad civil y la van de la mano
genial varios estamos acá quienes de
ustedes trabajan en el sector
empresarial ya sea en una empresa o
tienen su propio emprendimiento también
hay varios y hay alguno acá que está en
el sector público que trabaja en el
sector público también tenemos algunos
entonces yo en los últimos años estuve
aprendiendo un montón de cada uno de
esos sectores y hoy vengo a compartirles
un poco unas experiencias de cómo
podemos hacer para generar más sinergias
entre los distintos sectores porque
solamente trabajando juntos se ha
generar realmente un desarrollo
sostenible y acá bueno algunas imágenes
de ese camino que tuve en los últimos
seis años al volver de paraguay luego de
hacer estudios de noruega estados unidos
y tener el privilegio de ver un poco el
mundo más de 30 países y más de 100
ciudades y bueno volví y me metí primero
a ese mundo de la sociedad civil a ser
una activista social en la primera foto
que ven con mi bicicleta acababa de
terminar un viaje de 700 kilómetros
conectando tres ciudades principales de
paraguay con la idea de promover
ciudades sustentables ahora y formar
grupo de ciudadanos
demandan en una ciudad más participativa
más inclusiva más segura más armoniosa
con el medio ambiente luego me mudo al
directorio de la ong y decidido con un
grupo de compañeros formar una empresa
en la segunda foto me ven presentando
una revista que se llama compañía que
promueve el emprendedurismo y el
desarrollo sostenible en las empresas y
trabaje asesorando empresa y la empresa
sigue trabajando en eso y en eso me
llega una consultoría trabajo para una
consultoría para el ministerio de
planificación en paraguay y terminó
siendo invitado por el ministro a
trabajar en el gabinete y bueno y en
esta última foto me ven recientemente en
quito en la conferencia naciones unidas
sobre desarrollo urbano sostenible
llamado también hábitat 3 ya que dice
grandes pasos y conocí bastante eso y me
di cuenta que realmente existen dos
grandes noticias en esta situación y en
estos espacios una muy positiva que hay
mucho talento mucho conocimiento y
muchas ganas en cada uno de los sectores
para generar una transformación en
américa latina vi muchísimo en paraguay
otras parte del mundo hay realmente una
energía impresionante la mala noticia es
que no hay tantas sinergias no nos
conectamos tanto y las piezas separadas
no tienen tanto impacto como las piezas
juntas y como generamos eso porque todos
somos parte de la solución en cada uno
de los sectores pero el tema es que no
todos podemos ser parte de la solución
en el mismo lugar entonces tenemos que
elegir tenemos que enfocarnos y ese foco
para ti son las ciudades las ciudades en
pensar una ciudad juntarnos el gobierno
sociedad civil empresas y definir un
territorio en donde vamos a trabajar
juntos y eso es importante porque hay
espacio para todos porque vivimos en
distintas ciudades
en américa latina' 80% de la población
hoy vive en ciudades y centros urbanos
para 2050 70% de la población va a vivir
en ciudades entonces es ahí donde
necesitamos la mayor cantidad de
emprendimiento que generen estas
sinergias y voy a contarles tres
ejemplos de paraguay es mi país y el
primer ejemplo es ha ocurrido
al comienzo en 1991-92 un intendente es
el sector público verdad es feliciano
martínez que un día decide hacer las
cosas diferentes lugares de la oficina
sale y empieza a agarrar unas escobas
empieza a limpiar su calle le invita a
los vecinos y se genera lo que se llama
la revolución de actividad en unos pocos
años va a tener a reconocía la ciudad
más limpia de paraguay la octava más
limpia del mundo y fue era una ciudad
muy poco conocida a conocerse y hoy
tener una cultura hace poco fue en
realidad cal pasó por portera y al día
siguiente la ciudad estaba limpia porque
hoy es una cuestión cultural en ese
lugar y empezó con un emprendedor
la siguiente experiencia es de no más
del sector sociedad civil un artista que
en realidad tenía sus exposiciones en
todo el mundo y un día decide bueno voy
a volver a mi ciudad natal tan grande
voy a ver cómo puedo involucrar la mi
comunidad para generar una experiencia
en semana santa donde gente de todo el
mundo venga y viva está esta de estas
imágenes que ven es parte un poco de la
experiencia que es difícil digamos de
escribirla en imágenes uno tiene que
vivirlo y les invito a que en semana
santa vengan a paraguay a ver esa
experiencia y recientemente el papá
francisco visitó paraguay y se generó
todo un proceso participativo para
diseñar ese altar para crear el altar
simplemente usando la naturaleza
utilizando alimentos como maíz y cocos
con eso se construyó eso y es una
iniciativa donde fue más allá de esta mi
pasión esto lo hago pero veo cómo puedo
generar ese impacto y es un pueblo que
tenemos que ir buscando
otro ejemplo un grupo de empresarios
tenían bares competían por clientes en
el centro histórico de asunción que
estaba muy olvidado y dejado un día
deciden que por qué pasa si trabajamos
juntos y empezamos a organizar grandes
eventos lo hicimos todos
en un año crearon o crearon una
fundación llamada la asociación de la
movida del centro histórico y empezaron
a ver actividades culturales todo el año
ellos hoy ganan más dinero la ciudad
tiene más vida el país gana se posiciona
y nos beneficiamos todos entonces son
ese tipo de sinergias que existen en
paraguay que también existen en
distintos países del mundo lo que
tenemos que empezar a recopilar y
redefinir el éxito del emprendedor no
tanto como cuántas sucursales tiene sino
como cuántas ciudades en donde está esa
empresa tienen realmente un impacto
transformador y realmente cómo podemos
hacer cómo podemos iniciar para generar
todo un ecosistema a nivel nacional y
latinoamericano y global para poder
realmente comunicar estas ideas y
regenerar las sinergias y lo más
importante en una metodología que
utilizábamos tanto en sociedad civil
como la empresa como un gobierno es
poder comunicar de manera muy simple un
concepto y nosotros simplificamos ante
eran las
y ahora le agregamos una y vamos siempre
aprendiendo y hoy os quiero presentarles
cuáles son esas cuatro íes que
sintetizan la manera que vemos cómo se
puede integrar la primera vela y es la
de inspirar necesitamos generar un
proyecto algo que nos mueva a todos que
le mueva tanto a empresarios como a
sociedad civil como gobierno es decir
este es el sueño que tenemos en esta
ciudad en este pueblo y que eso mueve
que inspiren a todos ese es el primer
paso tener un proyecto la siguiente y es
la de informar tenemos que darnos cuenta
ser humildes que no sabemos todo que
quizás en otra parte del mundo que lo
hicieron que tuvieron los mismos
problemas años atrás y lo resolvieron de
alguna manera aprender en los errores
aprender los los aciertos globales
aprender de otros sentarnos a armar
debates generar planes de manera
participativa para informarnos y ver
realmente cuál es la solución global que
se puede aplicar a este territorio en
específico el tercer paso la tercera y
es la de integrar no solamente tener el
proyecto no solamente tener la
información y las herramientas
sino que tenemos que trabajar en red
integrarnos a otros a otros grupos de
empresarios a otro grupo sociedad civil
a otros grupos de otros gobiernos
trabajar en red porque eso es lo que
genera mucho más valor y nos ayuda a ser
mucho más eficientes en el trabajo de
general de desarrollo sostenible nuestra
ciudad nuestros países y hay una cuarta
y que también es muy importante que
tenemos que no olvidarnos que somos
parte de un sistema y tenemos que
generar incidencias involucrarnos en
política es el sector privado no no
queremos meter tanto en políticas por
debo las represarías pero si trabajamos
en red si tenemos un plan si todos los
ciudadanos están involucrados ese riesgo
de incidir políticamente se reduce y
entonces nos metemos realmente a cambiar
las leyes a cambiar las políticas a
cambiar los incentivos económicos para
realmente que se fomente el
emprendimiento que genera transformación
priorizar ese tipo de políticas porque
es la única manera que se genere
desarrollo local
y si bien es cierto que hay que ser
ambiciosos y tratar de cambiar el mundo
yo pienso que la única manera de
realmente de poder cambiar el mundo es
empezando desde la casa la primera casa
común que es la ciudad y por eso es
cierto con esta frase existiendo que el
que emprende para transformar su ciudad
actualmente logra que su ciudad
transforme al mundo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]